hello and welcome to this video Marine
skull that's from Iceland droid that
Iceland yeah I think that's Iceland yes
okay so default Bishop f4 and yeah okay
this c5 line against it it's em one of
the more interesting tries Bishop f4 is
also easy together i get an interesting
game against so let's see what happens
here yeah this is what they usually do
you can known yeah you can take and play
knight c6 this is what I'm recommend in
my repertoire this should be a route
piedra que seven black hands five which
is good for him and this is a decent
ending what we in this middle game can
always debate about how to call that
we're on black does have the double
pawns as a long-term idea at least to
play against own it's not that easy to
get something um really yeah really
exciting going on well here at least at
least i get i get the bishop pair which
is nice as in i mean it's at least
something where you have an idea how to
how to win the game in the long run
it's not the end of the world of course
I mean why does um not probably not very
happy about this pollution but it's um
not not going to be an easy win for
black or anything like that I wanted to
go I came to is seven but think I do
this first try to get this night to move
or coverage I mean I threaten to take
might be five I can take breaking a
center is going back now King to e7
night be five I can just move the bishop
again to before something like that so
what I want long term is to open this up
do you want to give me two bishops
against 290 what's the deal I cannot
really believe in that I mean a six ok
now that was idea ok I definitely have
night before as a zone as a decent move
with 93 ok don't want to spend more time
here
yeah 93 is the idea maybe roots III here
for white even though that's not a very
attractive move to play have to be
honest
interesting some what's the deal 9b five
I cannot go a six interesting move
hmm
it's not so easy here to find something
that is still kind of interesting which
is very very equal okay okay yeah this
is it was it was an interesting maneuver
here right to be five I didn't have that
on the radar at all
okay so if i move the bishop a7 is going
to be taken yeah my idea was to go just
a six and the 96 comes okay so not not
that again yeah as I said it's difficult
to do anything I don't really see myself
being in danger or something funky like
a night a night takes a seven and 96
check but that's not working right it
shouldn't work well this is probably
just equal on the other hand i mean i
remember is exactly remember what I
wrote in that bank or repertoire that
this these double points on the be foul
they are is going to stay there forever
and yeah this is definitely true you
always have some kind of plan like okay
just play on an oil and oil and maybe
hope that those double points cause
right some concern in the long run this
can still happen here yeah it's just not
easy to make any sort of headway b6
probably make this night look a little
bit weird I can go F 65 for some
activity check let's do that d44 hassle
not sure but it does it does make the
night look silly fettling b5 now it's
actually quite awkward so check check
and rookie five times Chang maybe rookie
five threatening be five winning the
night at four look III attacking be
three yeah I think he's in trouble him I
can take it or I don't see why not I'm
still threatening be five I know it's
got this square okay um how to do it i
think be five and Luke c5 is good
because he cannot avoid the trade now he
has to trade otherwise Roxy to him f 493
wins the house I know I'm ready to go
away for second porn on the run you or I
wonder know probably Shaq picking up
those is easier now it just like roads
here with the king check I can go to
defy whole city MO bit of a silly move
it's not not all that easy currently I
cannot move the porn how do I make the
pawn move her to go to be 4 12 f form
and I came now don't yet five seconds so
I have to make a draw which is a shame
oh ok I was gambling oops game drawn
oops ok yeah ok I should win this of
course but I kind of squandered away
time where did i squander away all the
time check yeah that was there was a
stupid move I completely stupid move I
just have to yeah break the blockade of
the night and win-win quite easily
Justin I 25 or see 5 or something and
here it's still ok it still was a little
bit tricky check k tricky tricky hits
it's easy still a term as I screw it up
at least at the end on time yeah so it
was a quite equal ish position but it's
again does this pawn is not going away
and you have to charge this long term so
yeah I mean maybe I should have gone is
a 60 and ask him about this Bishop and I
think you probably wanted to take but
here actually this is interesting
because I'm playing on this poor now the
c6 porn is never falling because of the
bishop it could be interesting I think
I'm probably winning the point
okay look here I just played in a simple
way but I think it wasn't bad check I
always have the weakness to play against
and now with this via tonight Luke 1c3
he has the night and out of squares
check yeah roughly here it gets very
difficult probably that that's to lose a
condition it's at minus 2 rupee 5 is
also interesting hear it there's nothing
nothing wrong with what i did this
ending is comparable to check easy to
win check I just I just took too long
just to too long for it it was also
pretty silly move now it's not that easy
at all now here we are talking about the
draw okay you blundered into a lot cider
with no time it was playing of course to
shining on my time yeah okay was
gambling with this spring mucha you need
like two seconds or so maybe for this
but I didn't have them ok guys thanks
for watching